this was me in 2019 but much more
interestingly this is my calendar in
2019 at the time i was working five
part-time jobs and studying two and a
half degrees
all at once and actually it was quite a
blissful time before i even knew that
this productivity video sphere even
existed so all of the tips and
techniques that i was using to manage my
time just were coming through myself and
through a lot actually of trial and
error and now a few years later i feel
much more read on the topic and very
interestingly i found that a lot of the
tips and formulas that i had developed
to manage my own schedule were very
similar to those that the literature had
found and that experts have found so
today i thought it would be quite
interesting to walk you through exactly
how i plan and schedule my calendar from
the bottom up for a very very busy week
and showing you all of the rules the
schedules the formulas and the systems
that i create to kind of make the ideal
week happen for me in a way these are
both evidence-based tips and tips just
based on my experience but hopefully
they will be helpful to you before we
get started little side note the ideal
calendar in my opinion is having no
calendar at all but if you are forced to
have one through your life circumstances
like me hopefully some of the tips in
this video might help but having said
that don't be too rigid with these
structures i fully believe that the less
structures there are the better but okay
let's get started so the first thing i
will do when building an effective
calendar is be aware of my three-part
split for the day this is based on the
fact that throughout the day two things
are guaranteed to be happening number
one is that my energy levels will fall
throughout the day and the second thing
is that the power of temptation will
increase throughout the day and what i
mean by the power of temptation is what
dan arley described as the ability to
continuously say no to things diminishes
throughout the day as we are doing this
the way that i like to visualize this is
having this huge pot of ability to
resist temptation and every morning i
start out with a fresh pot and what this
means is i might go to make breakfast
i'm going to make something healthy even
though i might want a donut but i'll say
no i'm not going to do this i'm going to
have a good healthy day but as i
continuously do this throughout the day
the ability to resist things that i
actually want to do becomes less and
less and less and this pot becomes
smaller and smaller and smaller and what
happens by the end of the night for
example you might recognize this if
you've been restricting food throughout
the day you'll have a midnight snack by
completely raiding the fridge so i keep
in mind that i'm going to have less
energy throughout the day and things are
going to get more and more tempting
throughout the day so it's going to be
much harder for me to resist things as
the day progresses keeping these two
things in mind every single day of my
week from a macro standpoint gets
divided into three main parts so the
first part of every single day is
reserved for activities that are high
energy and high temptation these are the
tasks that require a lot of brain power
or physical power and also that i can be
very easily tempted to do something else
so tempted to leave things that i'm not
enjoying that much these might be
studying for an exam this might be doing
a task for work which is not
particularly fun this might be a huge
project that i've just been
procrastinating on for so long because
it's not the ideal way that i want to
spend my time so all of the things which
i don't particularly love to do go into
this first part of my day because this
is the part where i am the strictest and
the part where i have the most energy
the second part of the day is reserved
for activities which are high energy
because i'm still buzzing at this point
and also activities that require
a little less resistance to do so this
might be going to the gym for example
because i actually enjoy doing this this
might be hanging out with friends
because i really enjoy doing this or fun
activities or fun projects or the fun
parts of studying that i would like to
engage in so these go into the second
part of my day and the last part of my
day is where i have the lowest energy
and the highest ability to be tempted by
other tasks so this is where
procrastination is very easy so keeping
this in mind i'm not going to leave like
this huge work project which i really
don't want to do for the last thing at
night because it's almost guaranteed i'm
just going to get in bed and think i'll
do it tomorrow so there's no point in
scheduling anything major or not fun for
this part of the day this is for my
personal creative tasks this is for
things that i would actually like to
spend my time on that don't particularly
require huge amounts of energy these
will go into the last part of my day so
in this way i keep this role in mind and
i have like this invisible three-part
division of my calendar every time that
i'm booking in tasks so if i have to do
something or if i have to work for
something in the week the first question
i will ask myself is how likely am i to
not want to do this task and how much
energy will this take so depending on
these new factors it will either go into
any part of my day the second rule is
the mission impossible rule and this was
a new one for me because i'm definitely
the sort of person who if i put
something on my to-do list i want to and
i physically need to get it done i will
not go to sleep until i've ticked
everything off and this used to be my
behavior in the past however i've
realized that this is not only a bit
problematic i'm sure you can see why but
also it's not ideal even for the tasks
that i am doing this very interesting
study in 1927 done by segment inside
narc siegnarck
basically said that our brains tend to
stay occupied with a task until this
task is completed and what this means is
if you start something but you haven't
finished it there will be a part of your
brain that's continuously focusing on
that task and you can use this to your
advantage if there is a huge project
like for example a essay that i want to
write or if you want to write a book or
if you want to do something really
really big that takes a lot of time it's
really good to put a time in your
calendar just to remind yourself that
this project exists so for example even
though i don't write my newsletter
strictly every single week i do have a
reminder in my calendar every week for
it because what that does is throughout
the week as i look at my calendar and i
see the reminder of oh i need to write a
newsletter it will open up this task in
my brain and even though i'm not
consciously thinking about it randomly
throughout the day as i'm working or as
i'm in the shower it might just pop into
my mind again and i'll go oh what should
i do for my newsletter and equally if
there's something huge that for example
i want to start a course i want to do
something big that i don't have a strict
deadline for but it's a huge task i will
just put this random deadlines in my
calendar just to remind myself that the
task exists and to open this in my mind
getting comfortable with not
accomplishing tasks and using a calendar
more as an inspiration and a guide as to
what i want to spend my life with tends
to be really really helpful and i found
that going from not putting things in my
calendar if i'm afraid i won't complete
them because it will really bother me to
actually putting them in my calendar
knowing that this is a mission
impossible that i'm not actually going
to do this much more helpful because i
end up doing those things much more if i
put them in my calendar anyways the
mission impossible is also something
that i keep in mind when i'm doing a
task anyway in a study done by phishnark
it found that if you are continuously
doing things that you don't enjoy or
forcing yourself to do work when you're
finding it unenjoyable it can lead in
the long term to procrastination or
failure on these tasks so i keep this in
mind a lot once something is too painful
or not fun or not enjoyable i just
stopped i used to be very good and very
proud of myself for overriding my stop
stop stop in my mind now i'm like no if
i'm not enjoying this we're done we're
taking a break we're moving on i don't
care that i've blocked it out in my
calendar if it's not good enough then
i'm going to find time for it at a
productive time later in the day or the
week but not overriding the signals of
your brain going that i must do this
because i thought i needed to is i found
in the long term much more healthier
next rule is the pr rule and i call it
this because both parkinson and
roosevelt come to the same conclusion
and it basically just states that work
expands to fill the time that you
allocate to it so it's quite a
well-known rule but i use it in a bit of
a different way so what this basically
means is if i say that i'm going to
write my essay in three weeks or i'm
going to write my essay in five months
i'm going to write my essay in three
days very often the quality of the work
is not going to be too different in
these three different forms so if you
give yourself a very very strict and
ridiculous deadline sometimes you will
end up doing a lot more than you
expected so this is one way around it if
you have a huge task sometimes if i have
to do something like create a sales page
i will give myself two hours to do it in
my calendar and i'm going to put myself
in the mindset of i'm forced to do this
now in this time only and then i will
get so much more done rather than
booking out a 10 hour shift for one day
and going like oh i'm just going to do
this slowly and get lunch and then do
this again which i mean is fine but i
get a lot less done even in 10 hours
than i get with a very intentional
two-hour stint and then just having fun
for the rest of the time so this tends
to work very well for me another thing i
do around the pr rule is that i will not
book work in my calendar i will only
book the finished product in my calendar
so what i mean for example is that if i
have to film this video there's a lot of
steps that go into it so i have to
research i have to think of title i need
to think of thumbnail needs to think and
edit the hook needs to actually script
the whole thing to do the research on
the studies need to put it together i
need to actually sit down and film it
need to export it edit it add the extra
layers of editing which takes so long
and then export it and then make it
ready and then put the descriptions and
all that stuff if i had to book all of
these different events in my calendar
it's almost guaranteed that i'm just not
going to do some of them so if i just
have this slot in my calendar for edit
this video i might come to that time and
be like oh i can do this later it
doesn't matter so i put none of this in
my calendar the only thing i will put is
let's say that the video is due to be
published on tuesday on tuesday i will
put a day event of saying publish the
video on calendar scheduling and what
this does is that it gives me full
freedom but also a lot of forced
deadline to get this thing done by then
so i'm telling myself i don't care when
you do this i don't care when you find
the time like just do it whenever
however fast or slowly you want to do it
i just know that it needs to be done by
this time and that puts me under a lot
more kind of positive pressure to do it
and gives me a lot more freedom rather
than allocating all of these slots in
the calendar would just fill up and clog
up the whole thing and also because
there's such small insignificant tasks i
can very easily go oh i can do this edit
when i do the export or i can do this
thing when i do that thing later and end
up doing nothing so giving yourself full
freedom with very strict finish only
deadlines i think is a great way to get
more things done the next role is the
morning story rule and i really really
like this because this is from jackson
mihai i'm so sorry i've tried this so
many times before him but basically what
he did was that he stated that people
that were very creative and very
effective in their lives always started
their day with something that they were
looking forward to even something tiny
it can be like buying your favorite
coffee every morning or it can be making
yourself your favorite breakfast or
calling a loved one or just having five
minutes to yourself outside in the sun
drinking your tea in the morning so it
can be anything really really small but
having something that doesn't
necessarily need to go in your calendar
but can go in your mind for what you
want to do the next morning will make
you enjoy your day a lot more and he
says if you get into the habits of this
your day will eventually be filled by
things that you are only looking forward
to so i take this role very much to
heart every morning i plan something
that i will enjoy so that's usually a
slow breakfast by myself for me but
whatever it is i know that there is
going to be planning around this time
the sacred time in the morning that
might even be 15 minutes or five minutes
but there is this time so anything that
i will start to schedule in will be
after this morning time for myself next
is the fun factor and this is my
favorite part of the calendar it's
something that only started doing very
recently i think ali mentions the fun
fact right i'm not sure what he means by
it but i thought it was very appropriate
to describe this there's this quote by
daniel priestley that says that good
nature is the result of ease and
security not a life of arduous struggle
so some struggle cannot be avoided but
the struggles that we can avoid and this
self-imposed kind of work that we need
to do might actually be affecting us
negatively in the long term so i've made
it a rule to force myself to do
activities that are fun either by myself
or with other people every single week
i'm very very aware of this i can be the
sort of person who can forget to
socialize or can forget to interact with
people quite easily sometimes especially
when i get very very kind of caught up
in work or i might just paint for days
in a row and completely forget to
interact with even my flatmate so um i
have to force myself to do this so in my
calendar i will book for example i'm
going to go to a gallery by myself or
i'm going to have dinner with friends or
i'm going to go to the movie by myself
or the movies with someone else or i'm
going to have a nice time with someone
this will be physically blocked into my
calendar and as i have an overview of my
calendar every week i will go okay
there's a healthy balance here of social
activity it will usually have a
different color to the rest of the
things that i am booking in but it tends
to be my favorite part every time i look
at my calendar it looks happy it looks
excited and also it kind of means that
it's not just working there and i don't
tend to hate it it's not like this oh
this terrible thing that dictates my
life and just schedules all my work
things it's kind of my life on a screen
in a positive way because i can organize
it and put in whatever i want so do not
forget the fun factor even if it's just
taking time every evening for yourself
but i quite i'm a huge fan of spending
time with other people so hosting a kind
of board game tonight at your house or
someone else's house a dinner a dinner
by yourself outside anything can be done
so would really recommend not forgetting
the fun factor in your calendar
scheduling that's how we go into
strategic over planning and nato gamdi
said that not only are we easily
distracted by mundane votes but we also
routinely forget small but important
things when we don't externalize them so
it's quite important to take all our
things that we want to do and things
that we are planning to do i kind of
write them down either as a to-do list
somewhere i like just pulling up my
calendar and finding a slot somewhere to
think about something or to do something
a very easy way to organize my life i no
longer keep to-do lists actually i just
put everything in my calendar when i
want it to be done or even if it's like
four weeks down the line get back in
touch with this person even if it
doesn't happen when it comes up four
weeks later i can go oh like in a week
would be a good time to meet this person
so it's quite good to have these slot in
there and use your calendar to kind of
accompany you in life rather than just
these strictly booked things and don't
be afraid to overbook it kind of
relieves your brain of having to
memorize so many things and keep so many
things stored and also it just helps you
kind of have things in place and once
they're there it's actually that much
more likely to do them if you're also a
fan of optimizing things for your brain
or better understanding it that's all a
brilliant documentary that i would
recommend is the curious brain on
curiosity stream which are very kindly
sponsoring this video this is a very
cool documentary series that kind of
goes into different aspects of how our
brain works how it organizes information
and thought how it interacts in society
and it's been
really really informative even as
someone who spends a lot of time reading
and thinking about my mind there's been
so much that i've learned and
restructured through this documentary so
i would really recommend it as a
wonderful watch if you want to check out
curiositystream you also get access to
nebula which is a streaming platform
where a lot of educational creators put
our videos together so you get an ad
free experience of all of these videos
and much more nebulous specials which
are very informative educational and
interesting the subscription for both of
these together is literally the price of
a takeaway and it will be linked in my
description you will have a discount to
get access to those if you want to join
me on nebula but otherwise thank you so
much if you made it so far i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day be
kind to yourself and others and
duplicate everything you think thanks
bye